quel est le point commun entre spirou
les figurines de la bataille
d'austerlitz et ses mini des corps de
james bond c'est lui cyril robinson il
crée des prototypes qui servent ensuite
de modèle pour la fabrication en série
de miniatures ici ils travaillent sur le
prototype de martin à partir des albums
on va pouvoir le projeter en trois
dimensions parce que le support est un
support de deux dimensions et il va
falloir recréer un volume et se projeter
dans ce volume là c'est peut-être ça le
côté un petit peu plus compliqué surtout
d'être dans les clous par rapport à ce
qu'il ce qu'ils demandaient chacune des
60 figurine sera ensuite validé par les
ayants droit avant d'être dupliqué ce
touche-à-tout travaille dans le milieu
des maisons d'édition depuis une
quinzaine d'années son nom est même
arrivé aux oreilles de la société de
production de star wars en 2007 pour
laquelle il a créé 40 prototype de
vaisseau un modèle comme ça c'est à peu
près en conception pur 3000 pièces à
assembler et après en moulage en termes
de moules on sait un moule qui va
demander une cinquantaine une
cinquantaine de pièces à peu près donc
ça commence à être déjà plus compliqué
compliqué mais pas impossible pour cyril
un ovni dans ce milieu il dessine ce
culte mais en couleur et il fabrique
même les moules de ses prototypes pour
les usines
bref il recrée de a à z ces univers
qu'ils ont bercé enfants au delà d'être
un grand enfant il ya aussi
la passion compte pour beaucoup et puis
avant tout je pense une affaire à une
affaire de nostalgie et la nostalgie
aller entre chacun en chacun de nous
c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne tout ça
ce qui est ce que les gens aiment c'est
justement c'est ça c'est de revenir à
leurs enfants c'est ce côté de
nostalgiques le dernier plaisir
nostalgique ce sont les personnages de
gaston lagaffe qui auront peut être
droit à une collection en 2019
la mouette de cyril a en tout cas déjà
été adopté par la fille de franquin
[Musique]